it's captivated much of the nation and
has become a runaway hit packed with
more twists and nerve jangling tension
than a best-selling spy thriller no I
refer not to what colored Greg's jacket
might be next edition of the pledge but
rather the BBC drama bodyguard pulling
in audiences of 7 million the drama has
already been accused of being too sexy
as well as being too politically correct
as there are so many powerful female
characters now some are saying
Islamophobic because one key scene
showed a female would-be suicide bomber
wearing the hijab and seeming to act
under the influence of her jihadist
husband critics have said it reinforces
negative stereotypes about Muslims and
more specifically Muslim women being
under the control of their husbands well
note to these dreary critics the
principle terror threat in this country
is from radical Islamists jihadi Brides
do exist and oh yes this is a drama not
a documentary look I agree with your
broad point that the people are getting
all kind of on their hind legs about it
that's all nonsense
but honestly Nick this is a fantasy and
a farrago you know I learned more about
politics and terrorism and feminism from
watching Game of Thrones and this
program because it's just nonsense I
know some other people people who
occupied the positions that are at the
center of this Home Secretary and so on
not one of them would react in the way
that the characters in this show do and
I understand it's a drama it's not
reality but at least drama has to be
related in some way to the universe as
we know it this is just crazy
all right well let's for some viewers
who might not be up speed this is the
key scene that's caused so much debate
then I'll come back to you
so I'm gonna come
so what to talk I saw and Trevor we've
been having far-fetched storytelling
since the days of Chaucer it just makes
no difference
yeah but you know the Wife of Bath
behaved like a real wife there were
things that then followed that were the
point about this is that if you're going
to represent this scene actually what
would have happened here is she would
not have been dressed like that
everybody knows that that's why that's
why al-qaida chose clean skins that she
would have been dressed in a way that
didn't draw attention to her my point is
simply but the way this is done it's
like a sort of it's like a kind of
cartoon fantasy it's not a real drama
there's no tension in it
but yeah I think you could say that a
boom almost anything Rachel you wanted
to get in there the key hole out here is
is drama well of course it's drama it's
dramatic reality but it can do I cannot
I just think Trevor I'm afraid to
completely disagree with you how do you
know how these people would react amber
rod secretary actually contributed a
piece to the Sunday Times saying a lot
of it was very accurate particularly you
know the relationship with the close
protection officers for example why
would a Muslim woman who is a rut had a
relationship at that but the other point
is is it I thought that the burden of
Nick's argument was that we shouldn't
attack this for Islamophobia because
drama beef with it by the way is its
massive massagin ism this is a program
which hates women of all kinds sorry
this is a program that represents women
in power actually witches and women are
in power the Home Secretary the
Metropolitan accreditor dick had a
format I mean and you think they would
behave
the one woman who's been who cabinet
minister woman who we know has suffered
assault of this kind remember what she
really have done what this woman you've
seen that really most offended me okay
big culture of I don't know why you've
got that view I take offense about all
sorts of things
the one thing I'm most offended me was
that there was a scene where the Home
Secretary woman and person who I think
is supposed to be the head of the
Metropolitan Police woman they have a
catfight they literally I mean they have
a catfight it's not repartee to women
cuz it's fine because that's exactly how
it's represented and it's settled by a
man my point is in that actually the way
this particular series treats women is
unacceptable and indeed we're coming
back to your point about Muslims it the
way it treats this Muslim woman who is
supposed to be a suicide bomber is
unacceptable and there's a who herself
this is what she says about it even now
in 2018 one of the tropes that keeps
being recycled over and over again about
Muslim women is that we were oppressed
we have no agency we have no voice we're
controlled by men we are unable to make
our own decisions
one of the sort of things that has come
out as a result The Bodyguard as well is
that these trips keep being repeated now
program makers have every right to
create the type of characters they want
but part of the issue is that there
simply isn't enough diversity and
representation of Muslim women so we
don't see black Muslims on screen we
don't see non hijab' women most of the
time when women are represented it's
through the hijab is a visible
representation tool yeah I mean she's
more thought author she's she's regard
did a respected person within the Muslim
country and you don't have to accept the
sort of knee-jerk reaction that you know
the media is against Muslims to accept
that this isn't the way to deal with
this topic
well I think the point I've got a cushy
font from the creator of bodyguard Jade
Mercurio and I think he says this and I
think he's right you need to watch the
whole drama for comprehensive idea of
who is plotting to do harm
he also says unfortunately the reality
of our situation is that the principal
tariff it's in the UK do originate form
Islamist sympathizers and that's the
point he's making and I think he's right
20 years ago it would probably been it
would have been only of course it would
have been all right
Michel I think we've gone massively
off-topic I've never seen this program
at all it sounds riveting I will
certainly be happy up on it but I
thought that your key point is there is
a scene a terrorist scene and it's
depicted by someone that's a Muslim
drink and I think that your point is
that people are outraged that they would
cast a suicide bomber has been a
stereotypical Muslim yeah yeah so my
point is all of those people that are
outraged need to just get a life because
the reality of it is that if there is
going to be a suicide it's how a suicide
bomber attack or a terrorist attack in
this country in today's climate the
unfortunate reality is that it would be
potentially well not potentially but it
would be by someone that would identify
as been a Muslim and be an Islamist
terrorist I don't know why we've gone
off a talking about whether or not this
is a good drama or not because to me
that's not the point
okay let's bring Rachel back in because
one point that Trevor made was was how
women are portrayed in it now you can
speak more strongly to that cuz I think
they get quite a good representation
what do you say well I think people have
noticed that there is an almost kind of
deliberate attempt to put women in all
the positions of authority and power
even the sharpshooters in the first
scene one female and and the bomb
disposal expert who came onto the train
to to deal with the potential terrorists
was a woman and I like it I mean I think
it it's not sex it's all over sexy it's
not silly in fact it actually reflects
the state of affairs and I'm pleased
with it a little the women are dim or
devious
and the winners they represent are women
who couldn't who could freeze molten
steel with a glance the real women and I
just think that they're getting a bad
deal out of this drama I agree with you
I I mean we all agree with Nick's point
that's why that's why I want to move on
to something okay what we do